quem quem inventou o amor
quem inventou o amor
renato russo cantou essa pergunta lá no
final da década de 90
blaze pascal falou lá atrás que o
coração tem razões que a própria razão
desconhece
já carlos drumond disse que as sem
razões do amor eu te amo porque te amo o
amor é um mistério para a humanidade e
poetas filósofos tentado entender o amor
e eu também
quando eu era um universitário
o coração partido foi entender porque o
amor é algo tão sublime mas que
machucava tanto e não descobriu nada
ainda o amor dá-me ainda é um mistério
mas eu consegui refinar minhas dúvidas
uma série de coisas eu conseguia avançar
e outras ainda não entendo é sobre esse
não é o entendimento que eu vou
compartilhar com vocês que é porque nós
nos dias de hoje
nos pautamos em alguns pilares que
existem há tanto tempo atrás da outra
sociedade para outras épocas
esses pilares são tão somente à
hierarquia
o sofrimento porque iraque
quando a gente pensa na união de duas
pessoas podem ficar juntas até que a
morte os separe a gente está falando de
casamento
a gente está falando de amor porque as
pessoas se casavam negócios poder
dinheiro terras política é o homem
pagava 1.1 homem poderoso forte rico
dono de terras influente enfim pagar um
dote ele comprava uma mulher que ele
considerava que seria uma boa mãe dos
seus filhos não tinha amor de um homem
poderoso aqui em cima e uma mulher um
pouco abaixo que seria dele a esposa
dele a vitrine onde ele ia pousar nos
eventos sociais
mas ali não havia amor
ela até queria esse amor já que vai
conviver com esse homem
poxa por que não fazer isso é legal mas
não pressionem essa mulher era a mãe dos
filhos tinha que ficar quietinha lá e
esse homem é viver os prazeres o
sentimento 60 com outras mulheres fora
do casamento
perceba que existe um amigo mas existe
um abismo 500 esse homem e esta mulher
não existe amor não existe felicidade de
seus compromissos sociais pouco se sabe
dessa mulher porque não se falava não
temos registros escritos
a gente sabe desse homem e das enfim das
inúmeras possibilidades que ele tinha
apenas por ser homem
alguns parcos para os registros por
exemplo da conversa de pech quando ela
troca cartas com uma bad um líder
religioso é de onde ela morava onde ela
questionava até onde vai a minha dívida
com o meu marido até onde eu tenho que
se se é empregada dele porque talvez
algumas coisas estão sendo exageradas e
esse líder religioso responde o seu
corpo e do seu marido
a sua obra de deus perceba que a mulher
ela não pode ser dela ela nada mas é
interessante que existiam outras pessoas
na sociedade inclusive então vamos
pensar aqui esse homem poderoso casado
com essa mulher mas tinha outros homens
aqui que fica aqui embaixo que olhava
com essa mulher fala meu deus que mulher
linda que mulher educada que a mulher
cheirosa que cuidam e essa mulher
completamente rejeitada abandonada
desamparada triste
de repente percebe que o empregado um
cocheiro enfim alguém naquela casa há
também fosse poxa como você tá bem
vestida com um vestido novo repara nela
e aquilo massageia o ego ela gosta
daquilo ela sorri e quando aquele pobre
coitado daquele empregado percebe que
ele tinha um sorriso da patroa ele
também gosta
aqui a gente está falando de um período
literário da história chamado mal do
século
caracterizado por ser a segunda fase do
romantismo onde os homens é tinha um
culto à mulher mas há uma mulher divina
uma mulher intocável uma mulher virginal
e um culto à morte
nessa época era quase que bonito morrer
por amor porque esse homem ele se
apaixonou esse vínculo tão forte essa
mulher
mas ele sabia que aqui também tinha um
abismo não poderia viver esse amor
percebam iraque o homem poderoso uma
mulher
o outro ouro aqui em baixo ela querendo
amor desse homem e esse abismo esse
homem que derramou dessa mulher um novo
abismo havia sofrimento esse sofrimento
o segundo pela quem ama sofre essa aí a
gente aprendeu isso a gente não está
sofrendo para se a coisa vem fácil não é
qualquer outra coisa é o lance
amor é amor num lance a lance
porque veja essa mulher queria fundo do
coração que houvesse algo legal com esse
marido e ela sofre porque não consegue
esse homem querido fundo do coração que
pudesse ter a possibilidade disso mas
não é muito poderosa para ele ea gente
como antes esse amor como utiliza como
contos de fadas
perceba as histórias dos contos de fadas
se não é toda uma história um drama de
dor sofrimento bruxas madrastas
maltratos e t7 certa de uma pobre menina
indefesa coitada
eis que então surge um príncipe que nem
nome é um príncipe e vai salvá-la
ou seja a turma toda do filme é essa
mulher sofrendo e tentando ficar com
esse mocinho ou não esse príncipe e
acaba como quando eles ficam juntos e
vão viver felizes para sempre
a gente não sabe o que acontece depois
que eles ficam juntos
a gente aprende que a gente come o pão
que o diabo amassou de tanto sofrimento
já consegui ficar junto com a pessoa e
quando fica eu consegui vencer na vida é
isso que eu queria agora é só curtir
felizes para sempre
não existe isso estou falando de
história gente como é que a gente traz
isso na nossa vida e porque eu vejo que
isso pode estar complicando as coisas
são
tudo quando a gente pensa que tem mais
pessoas se separando do que casando
o índice de divórcio aumentando ou novas
modalidades de relacionamento vindo
porque o que acontece
veja essa é a kia se isso não é
basicamente o jogo da sedução um cdos
o outro é seduzido e aí a gente fica
numa dialética perversa porque a gente
quer marcar a gente quer que as
borboletas no estômago a gente quer
ficar pensando na pessoa
só que esse esse papel é de quem está
embaixo de quem está sofrendo a gente
não quer sofrer porque se a gente fica
no papel de quem sofre outra pessoa está
poderosa
então quando a gente está conhecendo
alguém fica um jogo muito gostoso que
fica fazendo uma dança a gente está se
conhecendo a gente vai experimentando
papéis e como é que a gente vê isso hoje
em dia a gente conhece alguém eu não vou
responder a mensagem agora vou parecer
fácil
o que a gente está dizendo eu estou no
poder
eu não ligo eu sou muito difícil outras
oito pessoas que dela que vêm até mim
mas quando digo perverso é porque veja
assim quem perdi o jogo da sedução
ganhámos bem o sofrimento aqui mas essa
relação não precisa é ser inexistente
pode acontecer essa pessoa pode ser uma
pessoa que sofre mais aquela que cuida
mas aquela que se importa mais
mas é que sofre mais a pessoa que perde
o jogo da sedução ela tem o amor e aí eu
venho com a fala que não é de hoje para
trazer vocês duas perguntas das
perguntas que eu chamo de refinados
quando pensa o assunto - hoje em dia
uma delas é o que ganha quem ganha o
jogo da sedução
mas essa não é mais chata
tem uma que eu vou deixar para vocês
pensarem aí nesse final de semana e ao
longo da vida porque confesso que ainda
não têm resposta
se ao longo das nossas vidas dos nossos
pais dos nossos avós ao longo dos
séculos
nós aprendemos que o relacionamento
amoroso é e érico alguém é mais poderoso
alguém o que ama está baixo se submete e
sofre existe sofrimento existe
hierarquia existe diferença de poder
a gente entende que isso é um
relacionamento amoroso
será que se em algum momento da nossa
vida nós encontramos a possibilidade de
uma relação horizontal onde não há jogo
de poder onde não há sofrimento é que a
gente conseguiria dar conta desse amor
de fato e se feliz com ele nós de fatos
nós de fato estamos preparados pra ser
feliz no amor
[Aplausos]